zusätzlich kommen zu einem neuen video
und heute leute ist es ein bisschen
ernster gehalten denn ich muss euch
sagen dass ich so weitermachen möchte
wie bisher sagt grund sicherste manchen
youtube und er kommt einfach durch dass
das leben als bei youtube viel besser
ist sich martin wird alles falsch
gemacht man sie können 30 placement im
monat machen und die türkei gerade so
kennzeichnung und alles das juckt
einfach überhaupt niemand wenn ich in
kelsterbach okay wenn ich ohne luft
zerrissen alle schreiben geldgeile
bachtage und muss einfach sagen mir ist
natürlich als youtube selbstverständlich
nur ums geld geht habe ich mich
entschieden mein konto zu stellen nicht
mehr das zu machen was ich jetzt mache
mir einfach ag und jetzt werden nur
dafür ist die jahre dabei und jana wird
mich heute zur youtube- sein damit ich
endlich noch weise der mein geld
verdienen kann macht das ganze
dokumentieren dass heute kameramann und
für euch
kabul facebook-apps gewandelt heute
bilden für den vieler internet manche
bekannten jedem mist und post komplett
machen
wir können einfach drei festen von einem
video machen oder fügte ein wenig über
den dfb
ich muss mir einfach vorstellen dass ich
mir einfach viel geld kaufen öffnen
foundation auf befragen
mir gehts richtig scheiße welchen banken
auf dem ersten album führungsleute
gleichen artikel
schöne angebote komplett
[Musik]
ich stelle mir einfach mal im inneren
vor niemand mehr displays mache macht
viel höhere cpm kein adblock mehr so
viel verdienen möchte ich das doch
einfach hart genug zu zeigen wie man
mehr geld für diesen wenn ihr gerade
noch in der schule seit leute weniger
auch gleich eine ausbildung macht wenn
ihr es vielleicht studiert scheiß drauf
lag ich einfach schminken werdet youtube
das macht einfach nur spaß ja ich habe
angst dass du mir die augen aufschlug
das ist sehr gut es dauert ein bisschen
lang gesehen und gleich wieder in
größere fortschritte geschafft aber
irgendwas fehlt also die schränke sind
da
pinkl fans da fotos entfernt
folglich muss ich unbedingt mein größtes
geheimnis so und war zehn jahre lang
vorbereitet wo ich geboren wurde meine
eltern an stand drauf gewartet dieses
video machen und zwar habe ich die
kooperation mit mini ist es wirklich nur
toll so schnell so gut als einfach so
ein tolles produkt leute
jetzt wo ich die seiten gewechselt haben
wollte ich euch natürlich mal die
gelegenheit geben also zu fragen wie man
eine so tickt als youtube
deswegen habe ich natürlich absolut
welche fragen wollte immer mal einer
youtube einstellen gehen wir mal auf
eure fragen ein jahr also wissen ob war
musste ihr viertes videos richtig träge
rhade nächste frage warum springt man
sich entstelltes online dafür gibt
eigentlich nur einen grund und zwar der
dass man mit judy einfach mehr geld
verdient bei mädels immer mehr
zahlungsbereit sind als jungs man
dementsprechend mehr sachen verkaufen
kann mehr platz bekommen kann und unterm
strich einfach mehr geld verdient so gar
nicht verstehen was mit ihrem geld
machen die kosten angeht so schwer bist
du nach dem schminken 5 tonnen schwerer
oder nur 4,95 wirklichkeit immer die
waage stellen räumt in meinem fall
wartet sein leid make up sollte
natürlich einfach mag jetzt nur 83 kilo
extra aber erst leute ich habe mich
selbst noch nicht mal gesehen und wäre
deswegen begleitet mich jetzt erst mal
wie ich meine neue stück youtube
entdeckt
der spiegel wiederum leitet
du bist doch mehr geld verdienen konnte
das geschäft der brandnacht hat ihm
hatte ich noch dazu 20.000 oder so ich
weiß nicht woher kommt aber ich habe
einfach finster zwei millionen mehr am
konto
hier steht immer zwei millionen formen
geheimen orten der beauty youtube in
deutschland
für kein einziges bild
mal wieder sehen